WOUND UP WITH A CAREER HIGH 10
IN THE GAME.
WE'RE UNDERWAY WITH AN EARLY
>> John: J.T. MILLER PLAYING THE
WING IN THIS GAME. AGGRESSIVE PE
CHECKS.
1 TO GO ON THE POWER PLAY.
TIPPED ON NET, AGAIN TAVARES.
AND DEMKO THERE
>> John: BROCK BOESER JAMMED
FROM IN CLOSE..
MUZZIN TRIED TO TURN QUICKLY.
ON THE DOORSTEP BROCK BOESER
ANDERSON WITH GOALS THROUGH EKM
PUT IT HIGH TRYING
CHANCE.
MATTHEWS.
SANDIN!TART PERIOD NUMBER
TWO WITH TAVARES DRAWING THE
PUCK BACK.FF
HIS SKATE.
LEAFS TRY TO COME U U STICK ON
SHORTHANDED.
WON 6 BID.
AND DEMKO ABLE TO STOP
MARNER TOP OF THE CIRCLE.
TO THE GOA GOOD PLAY ON THE QUIK
SAVE.
BUT WATCH TAVARES.
HE LOOKS FOR A SECOND LIKE
HERE'S MARNER.
MATTHEWS KEEPS THE PUCK IN.
AUSTON MATTHEWS LONG SHOT OFF I
MRAZEK.
40 SECONDS GONE ON THEHACKS BY
MARNER WHO CAME IN, LOOKING TO
MIKHEYEV.
LANE.
THERE'S JUST AN EXCELLENT SHOTH
MOVE.
STICK QUICK BETWEEN THE LEGS
WITH THE PUCK AND A QUICK RETUR.
WITH THE BLOCKER THERE AND NYLAE
WHISTLE.
>> Craig: I SHOWED BEFORE SANDI
ATTEMPT BLOCKED.
YOU HAVE A MOBILE ACTIVE BIG
BODIED GOALTENDER.
>> John: A TU
AND ANY LEAF ATTEMPT TO APPLY
MRAZEK.
HERE'S ALEX CHIASSON.
CONOR GARLAND. BY KASE.
CHIPS AHEHE BUT
BOESER IS THERE. ON
THE BLUE LINE. WHILE.
>> John: "BRUCE THERE IT IS."
LOOK AT THEAS
OFFSIDE AT THE BLUE LINE.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> NO
REACTION WAS LIKE HE THOUGHT IT
G
TO THE BENCH AND HAD TO